-Junior, I am the number-two
Executive Vice President
at Santa Inc.,
who only answers to Santa,
Brent, and the board.
I can end that nose of yours.
-I'd like to see you try.
A lot of powerful people
need this nose to glow
so they can pay their mortgages
and send their kids
to private school.
So, by all means, go ahead
and try to stop this nose
from glowing.
-God damn it. You're right.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Sarah Silverman.
That was a clip from
your new show, "Santa Inc."
-Yes.
-Not for kids.
-No.
-Yeah.
-Not for kids.
-It looks like it might be
for kids, but then you hear
a "God damn it"
at the end of the clip,
and you're like, "Oh,
this is from Sarah Silverman."
-I mean, I think
it's the kind of thing
you want kids
to watch anyway, maybe?
-Like, cool kids.
You want a cool kid
to find their way to it,
right, that can handle it.
-Yeah.
-What is the premise
of "Santa Inc."?
-It's like the business
of Christmas.
It takes place
in the North Pole.
And it's, like, the year-round
business of getting ready
for that one night of Christmas,
and it's funny.
It's made entirely --
not entirely --
but many Jews came together
to create this.
Seth Rogen and me
and the creator and writer,
Ali Rushfield and --
But first of all, the elves.
I play an elf. Candy Smalls.
And elves are Jews in this.
They're Jew--
Because they can work Christmas
and...
[ Laughter ]
I think really elves are Jews.
-Yeah.
-I mean, like,
you know, there's no Christmas
without Jews.
Like, every Christmas song
you love is -- Jews wrote it.
Like, every single one.
It's crazy, these Jews.
-Yeah.
-I just made it other.
-But that's a very true thing,
that this --
You're not just making something
up about these Christmas songs.
There are a lot of famous
Jewish songwriters.
-Every Christmas song you love
is written by a Jewish person.
-Yeah.
-And Christmas specials and --
Yeah. I mean --
-Did you grow up
loving Christmas
or did you not
celebrate it at all
and had no take on it
one way or the other?
-We totally did Christmas
because I grew up
in New Hampshire,
in Bedford, New Hampshire.
Same as you, and so, you know,
Hanukkah is like
the Jewish Christmas,
but it's not a --
If you're, like, Jewy --
If you're very Jewish,
it's not a big holiday.
They just make it that way
so kids aren't bummed
when they live in New Hampshire
and everyone has Christmas.
But, yeah, we had, like,
a Christmas Hanukkah "bush."
You know? Whatever. But, um --
Yeah. There's no -- Listen.
Christmas has become --
And I think this talks --
The show speaks to it a bit.
You know, about
it's stuff and things,
but at its core,
it's about the birth
of the nicest Jewish boy ever.
You know? Like...
You know.
The only caveat is, like --
The only disagreement maybe
is Jews
are disappointed that he became
a messiah and not a doctor.
[ Laughter ]
You know.
-Speaking of very nice
Jewish boys,
your co-star is Seth Rogen.
He's right at the top
of that list, right?
-Yes.
-I mean, how did you
first meet Seth Rogen?
-You know what?
I didn't remember this.
But I did -- He does this thing
every year with his wife,
Lauren Miller,
called Hilarity for Charity.
He does, like, a stand-up thing
for Alzheimer's and, um --
Sorry.
I'm, like, really scattered.
And I just remembered
a joke my dad --
It's, like, an old joke
that my dad just told me about.
I'll just say it in two seconds.
The doctor says, "I've got
bad news and worse news."
He says, "What's the bad news?"
"Uh, you have cancer."
He goes,
"What's the other news?"
"You have Alzheimer's."
And he's like, "Oh, God.
Well, at least
I don't have cancer."
Anyway.
It made me think of them,
and then I laughed,
and then I felt like
I had to explain it.
So, Seth -- I'm telling
other people's jokes.
-I love it. Via your father,
which is wonderful.
I mean, unlike your dog,
I believe your father does like
this show, so this is great.
-He loves it.
-Very good.
-They just texted me like,
"We're recording 'Seth.'"
They don't talk --
Yeah, they do talk...
How I met Seth Rogen --
I didn't know,
but he introduced me
at Hilarity for Charity
as the first famous person
he ever smoked pot with.
And I was like --
I got on stage,
and I was like, "Is that true?"
Because we've worked
together since.
We played brother and sister
in a movie called
"take this waltz"
and we did
this short film together
and blah, blah, blah, blah.
And we've just known
each other through comedy.
Anyway, he said, "Yeah,"
and what it was
was when I was first
doing stand-up
at the Hollywood Improv,
I was in my early 20s, mid 20s.
And I guess he was probably
like 18 or something.
And there was a kid that would
come around who was like 18,
and he'd come around
in his, like, car
and be like,
"Do you want to smoke pot?"
And I'd be like, "Yeah."
And I'd get in
and drive around with him.
He actually grew up to be
a wonderful writer/director,
this kid Jonathan Kasdan.
But Seth was there
one of those times.
But he was just, like, a kid
that I smoked pot with.
-Well, that's really nice
that you could have
that experience with him.
-You shouldn't get in cars
with strangers with drugs.
You know, but I could
absolutely take him,
so I didn't feel scared.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I also think, like, kids
shouldn't get in cars
with, like, famous people
to smoke weed, either.
I mean, like --
-Right.
Well, they had the weed.
-They did have the weed.
You know what?
You're off the hook this time.
-Thank you.
-Hey, you guys,
that's Sarah Silverman.
New episodes of
"The Sarah Silverman Podcast"
are released on Thursdays,
and "Santa Inc."
premieres December 7th
on HBO Max.